I'm Cristina Hutchinson and I'm Corinne
Fisher you're the co-host of guys we
[ __ ] the anti-assad shaming podcast and
we're going to answer the Internet would
you rather live in a world where
everyone but you is male or female male
hmm I don't know both are bad choices I
think I just kill myself would you
rather be married to someone extremely
attractive or be extremely married to
someone extremely distressed by a
landslide I'd be extremely attractive no
it's a [ __ ] Power Move when you if I
call it 20 full [ __ ] when you
consistently date people who are
better-looking than you then they
realized oh my god like that girl has a
strong personality yeah she must be more
than what I think she would you rather
everybody talk about you behind your
back or never talk about you and I'll
talk about me behind my men section I
dare you I don't care yeah would you
rather have no friends or no internet no
friends no internet I don't either
all day yeah the Internet's fun you can
watch videos of like dogs or like the
things where the milk spills and the
arno and friends yeah it's funner to
watch my favorite internet video of all
time with kids one I see is there's some
old lady goes it's Joey gets me every
time
would you rather never have sex again or
never eat your favorite food again
never eat my favorite food again that's
really hard I don't even know what my
favorite food is anymore so yeah I'd
never eat my favorite food again you
have to choose between sex on the first
date or sex on the tenth date what are
you picking oh that's a good question I
mean there's so many variables is like
it do I want a relationship with this
person it's like every time every time
tense day now first date [ __ ] it tense
day yeah yeah I want to know right away
Diana I think what I'm getting you know
what I mean I just want the relationship
back and wait nine dates and then I'm
dipping it and you're like okay how much
money would it take for you to not know
how to read oh five bucks
how much does our Kelly have fired
he already blocked me on Twitter that's
fine I'm sorry where are we
would you rather watch your Oh watch
your parents have sex every night or
join in 109 oh my god oh my god I mean I
gotta lie I'd have to watch it because
I'm not joining in my dad to Taunton
climber am i having sex with my dad
yeah yeah yeah when someone - I'm five
foot three to six foot six so Howard
logisitics even gonna work okay come on
guys talk about you're [ __ ] your dad
I heard somebody over there going sheesh
who would you rather be a bad kisser or
I'm gonna put one not pronouncing words
would you rather be a bad kisser or give
bad head give a bad head because then
you'll have to do it supposed to bite
would you rather a guy last 30 seconds
or one hour one hour I'd be aggravated
no but if I knew he is a one hour all
the time I have like books and stuff
yeah I'm like a snack yeah yeah yeah
pepper and other interesting things in
there first what are both it's got a
camel back you can have sex with anyone
you want but they died immediately after
who do you have sex with Donald Trump
the first words that came to my head was
Russell Brand but that feels me
I don't know I'm answering from
knee-jerk you see I was going I was
going here on mo I couldn't have sex
with Donald Trump no matter what I would
for my country would you rather give the
first 90% of a [ __ ] or the last 10%
last 10% yeah the last time the
victorious part yeah I think told
there's protein oh yeah I was like I
think they're implying that you swallow
for this scenario but no you spit it in
the trash just put it back on their face
but yeah last 10% easy easy
yeah thank you thank you thank you